as a reminder today's event has been set
up to adhere to social distancing
guideline
guidelines as outlined by health experts
thank you
good afternoon everybody
i want to thank the colonial early
education program
here in calwick center for for hosting
us tonight
you know uh i just met sarah johnson i
thought i saw sarah
somewhere in here but she has a uh her
three-year-old son noah
who's a student here she said this
program does wonders
helping noah learn his letters and
numbers and socialize
with other kids and understand his
his emotions and develop his personality
and i met him he's what a
bright cute young man but like so many
parents
she's worried she's worried about her
job as a dental assistant and
the and notching changes in uh
in what she has to do to make things
work uh
she has she's noticing changes in noah's
behavior
since he hasn't been in school since
march as a matter of fact he said to the
principal
where my teacher can i stay here and
play is when we were in his classroom
and she she's had to learn or
lean on her parents
which many many people have to do to to
help her
get through it and it's really tough the
parents like sarah
places like this center and the
caregivers and educators who work here
also give me a great deal of hope
you know reinforcing my absolute
determination that i've been pushing for
over
two years to triple the amount of money
for title one schools
and in those districts like this one
where every child
every child in title one district is
able to have the benefits
of an education at three and four years
of age
that's why i couldn't think of a better
place to talk about the third plank of
my build back better plan for the
economy
this is about easing the squeeze on
working families who are raising their
kids and
caring for aged loved ones at the same
time sometimes separately but many times
together
it's about creating jobs with better pay
and career pathways for caregivers and
showing them that
dignity and respect that they deserve
but i know it's hard i know it's hard to
think of a future
when you're just trying to get through
the crisis at hand
i know that the uh that the case of
child
care facilities across the nation is
dire people are looking for
help desperately and they've had to
close their doors and lay off staff
and they're not getting the protective
equipment they need to reopen and the
virus hot spots where they exist and
they exist all over the nation
they can't reopen at all and we're in a
child care emergency
and it didn't have to be this way that's
why i'm calling on the president to get
the facilities and the resources and the
equipment that are needed and get them
to them
now enough each
day the pandemic death toll grows each
day
in some states more people test positive
the day before
and each day too many american workers
are still out of work and losing hope
it's been reported by the president's
staff
that the president is quote not really
working this anymore
he doesn't want to be distracted by it
doesn't want to be distracted by it
his own staff admits that donald trump
fails the most important test of being
an american president
the duty to care
for you for all of us
you know it's also been reported that
he'll block any funding for more testing
and tracing
in the next covert relief bill which is
being discussed right now on the floor
of the united states congress
just as states report record cases and
hospitalizations and deaths
continue to rise
this man simply doesn't understand he
can't deal with our economic crisis
without serving and saving and solving
the public health crisis for all his
bluster
about his expertise on the economy he's
unable to explain
how it'll actually help working families
hit the hardest
you know he's quit on you and he's quit
on this country
but this election is not just about him
it's about us it's about you
it's about what we'll do what a
president is supposed to do
president's supposed to care to lead
to take responsibility to never give up
that's what presidents are supposed to
do
over the last two weeks i've shared my
agenda for economic recovery
i call it buildback better because we
can't just build back to the way things
were before
we have to do it better and the first
plank of my buildback better plan
rejects
the defeatist view that automat that
automation
and globalization mean we can ensure
american workers
lead to a future made in america
made in america the second plank helps
us out compete
the rest of the world and tackle climate
change
i'll put millions of americans to work
and good union jobs modernizing our
infrastructure
while building a clean energy future
increasing
jobs today i'm outlining the third plank
of my build back better program
mobilizing a 21st century
care and elderly childhood education
workforce
to deal with the caregiving crisis and
it's a crisis
in this country if we truly want to
reward
work in this country we have to ease the
financial burden
of care that families are carrying
we have to elevate the compensation
of those providing the care the benefits
and dignity of caregiving workers
and early childhood educators even
before the pandemic
millions of working families are faced
with enormous
financial and personal strength strains
trying to raise their kids and care for
their parents or loved ones
who are living with disabilities this is
the so-called sandwich generation
includes everyone from an 18 year old
daughter caring for a mom
who suddenly gets sick to a year
40-year-old dad raising his child and
caring for his own aging parents
the joy and love are always there
but it's hard i know it's hard it's
really
really hard families are squeezed
emotionally
and financially they need help
but too often they can't afford it and
the professional caregivers out there
the home health care workers child care
workers
or more often women women of color and
immigrants
are too often underpaid unseen
and undervalued the pandemic
hits and squeezes and tightens
on everybody nursing homes have been hit
hard
if you're a front line worker you
struggle
to find safe child care for your kids
others of you become unexpected 24 7
caregivers
trying to keep your children safe and
learning while you continue to work
remotely from home
if you had to put your career on hold
indefinitely or senior hours cut or your
job lost
the confusion the confusion over school
reopening only makes things worse
you know in the last few months has only
underscored how vital it is
for families and older americans to have
more home care
and community care choices that fit
their real needs you know we're trapped
in a caregiving crisis
within an economic crisis within a
health care crisis
you're doing everything you can but this
president
is not if i'm your president
here's what i would do first let's start
by caring for aging relatives and loved
ones
with disabilities helping them live
independently
here's an example right now there are
800
000 people who are eligible for home and
community care
through medicaid who've already signed
up for it
but they're waiting for a phone call
phone call back
for some the wait is five years
five years my plan makes a bold
investment so states can clear the
waiting list
to make sure we ease the financial
burden for more families going forward
we have to make long-term federal
investments
we'll have a major innovation fund to
allow states
to test and expand successful ways to
improve
home and community care and increase
prevention
and reduce the cost of hospitalization
think of think of expanded vital
services like
rides to appointments meals
day programs for seniors making their
home safer them
it builds on an innovative and created
provision under the affordable care act
the very program the president
ceaselessly is trying to gut
for example there is a pilot program now
in 27 cities in 16 states
where a nurse an occupational therapist
and a handyman come to the home that's
caring for an aging family member
they might not be able to cure mom's
alzheimer's
but they can make sure she doesn't break
her hip so they walk through the house
this is what's going on now
and they install handrails in the right
spots
in the house in the bathroom or they fix
the door
that's stuck so she doesn't trip
while she tries to open it it initially
found
that about three thousand dollars in
program costs yield more than
twenty thousand dollars in saving to the
government
from hospitalization to other reasons
simple steps to save lives save money
and provide
critical peace of mind here's another
example
whether you live in rural north carolina
or central philadelphia
people of color are economically
distressed communities face
punishing health disparities from a
system of systemic discrimination
they don't have health insurance they
don't see a doctor
sometimes language is a barrier and they
slip through the cracks
slip through the gaps so their treatable
condition
because they can't afford to go to the
doctor becomes a chronic condition
that's why community health workers are
real heroes
they go into these communities they make
sure folks are getting the care they
need
my plan puts to work 150
000 more of these workers in our
communities throughout the country
these are the things we can do now
secondly we can also make high quality
child care affordable and accessible
my child care plan is straightforward
straightforward
every three and four-year-old child will
get access to free
high quality preschool like students
have here
and low and middle income families won't
spend more than seven percent of their
income
on child care for children under the age
of five most hard-pressed working
families
won't have to spend a dime here's how it
works
we can either they can either decide to
get up
to an 8 000 tax credit for child care
for middle class family with a couple
young kids spending 300 bucks a week on
child care
that means an annual savings of eight
thousand dollars
in their pocket because it's a tax
credit
it means everything for working families
living paycheck to paycheck
or the federal government would send
funding to states
which then work with child care
providers to cover the cost
for working families with young children
over seven percent of their income would
not have to be
would not have to be spent
so say both parents are working working
and need child care
you go to childcare.gov
which is created under the obama biden
administration to help fund child care
that works for you under my plan it
takes you
to your state website local child care
centers
pop up you can call or fill in your
information
you apply to which one you want to go to
the state then sends you a letter saying
you're approved and lays out the amount
you're going to pay
the state sends that information to the
child care provider
and then the state reimburses the child
care center
on the back end you just pay
what you're supposed to pay not a dime
for some working families
and no more than seven percent for
anyone else
you can do that this would save families
thousands of dollars but more
importantly give them peace of mind
there's other common sense steps we can
take like expanding tax credits for
businesses
to build child care facilities on site
so you can go to work with your child
put them in a child care center that the
company got money for a tax credit for
building supporting more and more
and giving peace of mind to a family and
when you're finished work
take that child home supporting more
aftercare weekend and summer cares for
fam
programs or families third
we expand access to caregiving
we need to pay and support caregivers
beyond what they are now
they're doing god's work but home health
workers aren't paid
much they have few benefits
40 percent are still on snap
or medicaid so my plan is direct
it gives caregivers and early childhood
educators much
needed raise no one should have to work
more than one job to make ends meet
under my health care plan that defends
and expands obamacare there will be more
affordable health insurance
i'll make sure these workers have an
effective way
to unionize and collectively bargain and
protect their rights and earn benefits
this plan will help workers especially
those without a college degree
help them gain new skills in good pain
industries like health care
it provides new pathways to advance
their careers
for example a home health care worker
can have access to training
needed to become an emt or a nurse
or physician's assistant or even a
doctor
or the early childhood educator can
receive coaching
to keep delivering high quality learning
experience
we can do this the bottom line is
that a mobilized caregiving and early
education workforce
would save families time and money get
their loved ones the care and early
childhood education they need
and put more people to work allowing
husbands and wives to go back to work
and provide many people the opportunity
to get a job
that's a decent job caring
it keeps seniors in their homes it's a
triple win
if they choose that and recognize the
realities facing modern families
and provides them the much needed
economic support in the middle
of a pandemic just imagine
if we can put three million americans to
work
in new care and early childhood
education
and combined with my proposal to provide
families with up to 12 weeks of paid
family leave and medical aid
we can free up millions more people to
join the paid labor force
increasing economic growth meaning at
least two million additional jobs
more economic growth for the nation
this is a fresh bold way to build
a critical part of the labor force and
help us recover faster and stronger
we usually talk about jobs packages
there's a big push on
shovel-ready jobs i'm the guys you may
remember
manage the recovery act of 800 plus
billion dollars we always focused on
shovel-ready jobs what we could do
immediately to get the money out in
communities
but that's what care jobs are they are
shovel ready
the workers are ready now
these jobs can be filled now allowing
millions of people
primarily women to get back to work now
increasing the growth of the gdp and
family income
that's the right thing to do for our
families
and our most essential workers and it's
a smart thing to do
for our economy today millions of our
people
can't fully pursue the jobs and careers
they dream of
due to the caregiving squeeze that means
tens of billions of dollars less in
wages each year
for our working families means more
disruption for our business
fewer jobs and growth
in our economy slow
this is both a moral and an economic
imperative for the nation in my view
and the way we pay for it is by rolling
back unproductive tax cuts
some of the two trillion dollar tax cut
the president put through
closing loopholes unproductive tax cuts
for high
income real estate investors while
ensuring high income earners
pay their tax bills we invest that that
would add up to 775
billion dollars over 10 years we invest
that in building our economy back better
than it was before
growing the economy stronger and
tomorrow
i'll be joining a virtual town hall with
seic
sciu members home care workers fast food
workers
janitors to hear directly from them
about why this matters so much to them
because you see this is about something
bigger
this is about dignity and respect
for working people and that's precisely
what this election is all about
dignity and respect
the american people know
they're not being afforded dignity and
respect to many of their jobs
the american president has a duty to
care for all of us
to see people where they are to
understand
what they're going through and what they
want to be
as many of you know i was a single
parent for five years after my wife and
daughter were killed and my two boys
were badly injured
even though i had a lot more support
than a lot of people going through tough
times a day
it was hard
it was hard if i didn't have my mom my
sister and my brother
i don't know how i've been able to
afford it
then six years later when jill and i got
married i said how difficult it was for
her to start
her teaching career while being a new
mom with two kids in school
we cared well actually they weren't in
school yet now that i think about it
we cared for our parents at the end
my dad was months in hospice in our home
same with my mom and our entire family
was there for our son bo
when they came home from a year in iraq
with a cancer that wasn't whether he'd
live is just how long he would live
we know what it's like months upon
months
we know so many of you are going through
the same thing without the kind of help
i had
but now everything everything feels
different
there's just that feeling
that sense where you just don't know if
everything's going to turn out okay
but i'm here to tell you that it can be
and it will be
you know my dad was an honorable decent
man
his great regret he never got to go to
college
my dad like many of your parents got
knocked down a few times
but he always got back up he worked hard
to build a
great middle-class life for our family
on mayfield and clemont
but he used to have a saying he'd say
joey i don't expect the government
to solve my problems but i sure in hell
expect them to understand my problem
i understand to my very
core and i also know
that together we can do this
this is america we don't
settle we aspire
and we succeed so let's get the
heck up and get it done
let's get to work as i go out of my
grandpa you've heard me say this many
times got to my grandpop's house up in
scranton when dad lost his job when he
lived with my grandpa
every time he'd walk out she'd tell joey
keep the faith
and my grandmother y'all know joey
spread it let's go spread the faith
we can do this there's not a single
thing we cannot do
thank you for listening i look forward
to having your questions at another time
but i'm off to another event
thank you principal thank you for having
us here appreciate it very very much
thank you senator
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you